The refactoring you just
completed gets our code
ready to use the weather provider.
For this quiz, you're going to
code the addLocation method.
As you can see, this method takes
a locationSetting, cityName,
latitude and longitude for
the new location.
If the location already exists, we
return the ID of the existing location.
If we add a location,
we return the ID of the added location.
We can do this by first
querying the content provider,
to see if the location
query already exists, and
only performing the insert
if it doesn't yet exist.
Uncomment test add location
within test fetch weather task,
to validate your solution.